this is what they prepare for within
just eight minutes of the first call
armed police units had caught up with
the attackers and killed them yeah why
the police did come us you know quickly
and then they took control the situation
basically telling everyone to evacuate
and to get as far from from the place as
possible
[Music]
the police teams fired 50 rounds one
member of the public sustained gunshot
injuries but the decisive officers saved
lives the situation these officers were
confronted with was critical a matter of
life and death three armed men wearing
what appeared to be suicide belts they
had already attacked and killed members
of the public and had to be stopped
immediately indeed I'm not surprised
that when faced with what they must have
feared were three suicide bombers the
firearms officers fired an unprecedented
number of rounds to be completely
confident that they had neutralized the
threat that those men posed
forensic officers were soon scouring
multiple sites hundreds of CCTV cameras
potentially thousands of witnesses to
speak to its another complicated
fast-moving terror investigation more
raids more arrests just two weeks after
the Manchester Arena bombing and three
months after the westminster attack
which also saw a vehicle hitting people
on a bridge and a series of stabbings
the police don't believe they're
directly connected but there's a clear
pattern it's forcing a tougher response
unprecedented numbers of bullets used
stun grenades used to get into the flat
here special forces in the mix almost
everything now is being thrown at these
investigations and then there's the ones
that they are managing to stop another
five terror plots halted in the UK since
the westminster attack even though the
threat level had recently been
downgraded from critical to severe the
levels of armed police patrolling London
and other UK cities meant the response
was about as quick as it can be it's not
just that police got there in eight
minutes
it's that highly skilled super super
trained marksman got there and dealt
with it and contained it within eight
minutes the coordination of policing
across the UK is now absolutely
fundamental to this you know this is not
a London issue or a Manchester issue
this is a national issue and deserves a
national response this show of strength
is deemed as proportionate to the threat
but everyone knows it can't solve
terrorism on its own Tom Parmenter Sky
News East London